[Music]
Thomas King is an executive in the
world's largest internet exchange based
in Frankfurt almost every email video
and data file that sent in Germany
passes through these cables this digital
data flow has more than tripled over the
past 10 years the amount of Internet
traffic is measured in terabytes per
second at peak periods his company
handles 5.5 terabytes per second slide
mackenzie foster you can picture this is
1.2 million people sitting at home
streaming a video in hd-quality on their
television mobile phone or smartphone
all at the same time that combined data
volume is what travels through D cakes
Frankfurt each and every second was
equally
direct index one for mihika jakob hagen
works for interaction a company that
provides data center services at
internet exchange points interaction is
currently expanding its operation in
frankfurt the new facilities are being
built on former industrial sites which
are still relatively affordable
Frankfurt is a hub for fiber-optic
networks including ones that connect to
Eastern Europe and beyond vast sums go
into maintaining their infrastructure
this new complex for example cost about
100 million euros bogna Don we build a
new data center every year demand is
very high sometimes will already have
least half the space in a new data
center before it's even opened its doors
the table yeah security is extremely
tight at data centers though none of the
data that passes through these
air-conditioned rooms is actually stored
here it's all through traffic made up of
a vast number of connections from all
over the world but how secure are the
data superhighways that entire
industries rely on benign until ignored
life one internet hub a larger internet
hub with a malfunction it could have an
effect on an entire region you might see
slower response times for example but
generally speaking the global internet
would still work colleagues in the US
wouldn't really be affected by a
malfunction in Europe for instance when
I'm always fighting a war between each
team it become Maximilian planted is a
software developer who specializes in
industrial digitalization his company
was commissioned by a control box
manufacturer to build this smart factory
of the future a showcase for what might
be possible in industry 4.0 for example
the control boxes are designed on a
computer the 3d virtual prototype is
transmitted online to the production
area where it's then built without
internet hubs this transmission would be
impossible
bommali for houses we have all the
prerequisites here we have been
expensive sensors software we have great
automation components we have cloud
applications we have telecom
infrastructure that's everything we
really need to make the next quantum
leap I'm seeing new ideas new use cases
developing everywhere Italian oil use
cases no ETH Dean industry 4.0 will also
give Thomas Kings internet hub a major
boost the quantity of data in
circulation will also increase due to
the rise of
animals and virtual and augmented
reality
Karimi song they he can't tell you
exactly which of these technologies will
come out on top
but I can say that the future will bring
increasing digitalization with young
people as our world goes ever more
digital at work and at home more and
more of our lives will pass through
cables like these data is the currency
of the future and that currency will
depend on data hubs like this one in
Frankfurt